welcome back I'm now on page 460 and
we'll start with the number five and
they have a little drawing for us see if
I box like that I'll do it in yellow so
the box looks something like the box
looks like this like that then they have
a couple points here they have that's
too dark so you have point a B C and D
and the question is in the figure above
a path from point A to point D a to
point D is determined by moving upwards
or to the right along the grid line so
you have to move along the yellow lines
how many different paths can be drawn
from A to D that do not include either B
or C so we can't have either B or C in
in our path that goes from A to D so the
way I think about it is which of the you
know if we call these yellow lines roads
I guess you know which of these roads
would be unusable if I can't go to B or
to see well let me mark the unusable
roads
well unusable roads would be the roads
that their only purpose is to get to B
or go away from B or get to C or go away
from C so for example this road right
here all it does is go towards B or go
away from B so we can't use that because
we're not gonna go through B similarly
we can't use that road can't use this
road and we can't use this road right
because those are all the roads that
come to and from B so we're not gonna
use this the only reason why you would
use those roads is if you went through B
so you can't use those and similarly for
C same thing you can't use that one
can't use that one can't use that one
and can't use that one so what are we
left with I mean we might as well we
might as well just erase those roads
right because they're they're kind of
just messing up the picture right so let
me just erase them and I can I can well
that's good so let me erase all the
roads that I can't use I can't use any
of these because I can't go through a B
or C and then it's gonna start looking a
lot clearer then the problem gets really
easy so these are all the roads I can
use to go from A to D so how many paths
are there well I can go that's one path
one I could do this two paths three
paths four paths and that's choice B I
hope I'm right at least my choice to
exists problem number six problem number
six if 3/7 of n is 42 so if I write that
algebraically that's just saying 3/7
times n is equal to 42 and they want to
know what five sevenths of n is so they
want to know five sevenths and well to
solve for n here I just multiply both
sides times the reciprocal so let me do
that so seven over three I'm just
multiplying both sides of the equation
by 7 over 3 so this cancels out right so
we could say n is equal to 7 over 3
times 42 and now we want to know 5/7
times n so we just take this in place it
here so it would be five sevenths times
this thing right this is n times 7 over
3 times 42 and notice I just kept it
that way cuz the sevens ended up
cancelling out so I have to do less
arithmetic so scratch those out and then
let's see five times 42 over 3 let's see
42 what's 42 divided by 3
it's what 14 right because 30 and 12
right it's 14 so this goes to 1 this
goes to 14 and 5 times 14 is 70 and that
is choice a so all you do this you can
just solve for n and then multiply by 5
sevens not too fancy this is probably
one just to see how fast can you do this
type of problem clear image invert all
right I'm on problem number 7 and I'm
getting sleepy I shouldn't I'm just
gonna go to bed after this video
all right the figure above well let me
draw the figure above have that yeah you
know what this figure is for just yet
and then they say a b c d e and f and
well now let's read the problem the
figure above shows the top view of an
open square box that is divided into six
compartments with walls of equal height
each of the rectangles de and F have
twice the area of each of the of the
equal squares a B and C so they're
saying you know D is twice the area of a
I guess right the way I drew it it looks
like a little more but we know that this
is my Sarah this okay when a marble is
dropped into the box at random so it's
kind of being dropped from above into
this box it falls into one of the
compartments what is the probability
that it will fall into compartment F so
the way you really just have to think
about it's gonna it has it it has an IVA
marble has an equal chance of falling
anywhere on this Square and so if you
want to know the probability that it
falls into f you just have to figure out
the fraction of the area that f is of
the entire of the entire square so if we
said that you know a has an area of X
then B also has an area of
and see also has an area of X and they
told us that these are twice these so
this would be 2x this would be 2x and
this would be 2 X so the total area
would be what it would be X plus X plus
X so 3x plus 2x plus plus plus 2x so
these three are 6x plus 6x so the total
area is 9x right 9x is the total area of
the box I mean we don't know how big X
is 9x it still there in the box and F is
2x right F right here is 2x so the area
of F area of F over total area total
area I don't like this toothpaste to
blue color but but we'll deal so the
area of F I wrote here before I
scratched it out is 2x over the total
area is 9x and the x's cancel out so f
is 2 ninths of this total I guess boxes
area so there's a 2 ninths probability
that I've robbed marvel dropped randomly
on the on to the on top of this box
what's kind of a uniform distribution
anywhere in the box there's a two ninths
chance that it will fall and do I guess
you know cubby cubby II and I sorry
cubby F and that's that's what they
asked us in the question and actually
would also be too nice it would fall
into cubby hole because it's the same
area problem number 8 if a and B are odd
integers a and B odd integers which of
the following must also be an odd
integer these are fun all right
so choice one they give is a plus one
times B well they say it can this be odd
well let's just try it some numbers
let's say a and B are three and five
right these are two odd integers if a is
3 then a plus 1 is 4 times 5 this equals
20 so we immediately we get it we end up
getting an even answer and that makes
sense because if you take an odd number
add 1 you get an even number and
anything times and even is even so it's
not going to be choice one choice one is
gonna give us an even number actually no
matter what
choice two choice 2a plus one plus B so
we figured out that a plus one this is
going to be even and we know that B is
odd and you could try this out but if
you take an even number and you were to
add it an odd number to it you're gonna
get an odd number and that makes sense I
mean you could you could try it out with
a bunch of different numbers but that's
always going to happen I mean if you
know if it because if you had an even
number to an even number you get another
even number and if you add you know one
more an odd number anyway I think you
get the point and you could try it out
with our three and five examples that
wouldn't prove it for sure but it does
work for that example and then similarly
a plus 1 minus B it's the same notion I
mean you could try it out with some
numbers but if you have an even number
here because an odd plus one is even and
then you were to subtract another odd
number you would also get an odd number
so the choice is e see you soon